my mom was not [ __ ] with the tattoo
pouches old-school I'm sure she's happy
for me be proud of your mom you see me
it's all working out I got the nan ty
dolla sign because my name is ty I like
money
I like kid money my homeboy a started
calling me Dallas on it just started
happening everyday and then I said it
one time on a song and he went crazy and
then I just stuck to it my first tattoo
was when I was in like ninth grade it
was here on my arm it was a treble clef
I drew the treble clef that [ __ ] was
whack so I end up getting it covered and
now it's not there anymore over it it
goes into another picture of my brother
down the gates my brothers in prison
right now for a crime that he didn't
commit
have a lot of portraits like on this arm
my brother
what daughter what grandma or pops what
grandfather [ __ ] costs all of us for a
rusted piece all these portraits are
those are definitely my favorite my
family you know LA South Central oh my
god Nene
he's from Compton he's only does all of
our tattoos he's great at portraits
clearly I also have a lot of gargoyles
my last name is Griffin like the one of
my chest it's a big-ass Griffin right I
like certain times like online I'll take
pitches people will be like what the
[ __ ] is blue ty dolla sign's at devil
worshippers I'm like [ __ ] like that
because I have this big-ass Griffin
Griffin's like to protect you throw me
the temple in your body is your temple
so that's what that's about
no Devils [ __ ] glad we got to clear
they're not fun
most painful tattoo for me was my
fingers I got free TC you know my first
album fast everybody from my squad has
these we get everything fast you know we
also all have pushes anybody that's a
real-time Dallas on thin you got to be a
fan of DJ mustard you got to be a fan of
yg and there's about a thousand of us
that have this pushing you know we're
pretty deep out here
I got p.m. a positive mind attitude on
the back of my neck and next I'm gonna
get their big guys logo right here on my
ribs this was from my homeboy Shepard
rest in peace chef BAE you made a
[ __ ] weed palm tree bro you know I
hope you hear me up there bro it's kind
of [ __ ] up but it's all good man I'll
let you forever gonna shout to check
these most recent this skull on my thumb
put my next one I'm gonna get the Bad
Brains logo Bad Brains is probably my
favorite band ever HR is my idol
I recently hung out with them on my last
tour they don't judge me tour this is me
from back in the day
tiny Vito you throw me this me as a
pitbull man my big help me for my hood
big beat he has them they're the same
thing like I'm his little homie this is
another matching tattoo type I I got
would Jesus do you coming I got it on my
head I cheat people good and people
cheat be good and I'll get blessing
after blessing I just have my mom's name
Phil destroy my daughter's name jaylen
crystal joy my cousin's name
raynelle joy my sister Angelique crystal
joy as you see all the females have the
middle name joy and our family is full
of joy happiness positivity
the biggest poppy hip hop tattoo artist
for me growing up was this guy named
cartoon and I recently hung out with him
because I have a lowrider he has
lowriders a gang of him certain times
when I go on ride on a Sunday
I'll call part-2 only Tweety where's
Kalifa mustard by gene we all take on a
lowrider zone just cruise through LA I
finally got to link the cartoon he still
hadn't done a tattoo on me I'm I'm
sticking to his name is she
[Music]